MARTIN OMANDER: Hi, Aaron.
How are you doing?
AARON WANJALA: I'm
doing great, thanks.
MARTIN OMANDER: I've
been asked to start
building a new inventory
tracking system on Cloud Run.
We use Cloud Run,
which is serverless,
to reduce the Ops work needed.
The application will use
Java and Spring Boot,
but I'm not sure how to get
that started on Cloud Run.
AARON WANJALA: No
worries, Martin.
It's actually pretty
simple these days.
Let me show you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So remind me again, what kind
of app were we building here?
MARTIN OMANDER: It's
a pretty standard web
app with an HTML
user interface and it
will connect to a database.
AARON WANJALA: All right.
Well, first things first, how
about we get a simple service
created and deployed?
MARTIN OMANDER: Sounds
like a good start to me.
AARON WANJALA: We'll start
by making a new Google Cloud
Platform project for your app.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
And we can call it
inventory-tracking-app.
AARON WANJALA: Perfect.
Once that's created, we can
open up the Cloud Shell.
MARTIN OMANDER: Do we need to
use the Cloud Shell for this,
though?
AARON WANJALA: No,
that's entirely optional.
As long as you have the gcloud
command-line tool installed,
you'll be able to do everything
from your local machine
if you prefer to do that.
MARTIN OMANDER: Excellent.
Well, I will use the Cloud Shell
to get started for convenience.
I'm used to using the wizard
at start.spring.io to get
new Spring Boot applications.
AARON WANJALA: That
should work great.
All we'll need is
the web dependency.
It may be easier to use the
command-line version of that
to get the ZIP file in your
Cloud Shell environment.
I sent you the command.
Did you get it?
MARTIN OMANDER: Yep, I see it.
All right, let me run it.
Looks like I got a ZIP
file with a starter project
like I'm used to
from start.spring.io.
I'll just unzip it here
and open the editor.
OK, all set.
What's next, Aaron?
AARON WANJALA:
Well, that command
gave us a good starting point.
But we'll need something
to give us a sign of life
once we're running this.
Let's add a Hello World
endpoint to help us with that.
MARTIN OMANDER: Sure.
I'll just add a
HelloController here.
It will return a
placeholder inventory
count of a placeholder
product for now,
and this is just so we can see
that all parts of the system
are working.
Now to get started, how
can we get this running
from the command line?
AARON WANJALA: We can
actually run it the same way
you would on your machine.
Then we can hit
the Preview button
in the top right
of the Cloud Shell
to see it in your browser.
MARTIN OMANDER: Mhm.
There it is.
Very nice.
So the application is
running from my command line.
I can use this for
testing as I build it out.
Now how can we get this deployed
to Cloud Run up in the cloud
so others can test
the application?
AARON WANJALA: In
the simplest case,
we can do it in one line
with gcloud run deploy.
MARTIN OMANDER: Wow.
That is a short command.
But is there a way I can
see what kind of magic
is happening behind
the scenes here?
AARON WANJALA: Absolutely.
You'll be prompted
for a few things
during the run deploy command,
like providing the source code
location, providing
the service name,
enabling the Cloud Run
API, selecting your region,
and enabling Artifact Registry.
MARTIN OMANDER: Hmm, I see.
I did that.
Now I'm being asked if I want to
enable unauthenticated requests
to this service?
AARON WANJALA: Yeah.
To make it easy to
test here, we'll
want to allow
unauthenticated requests.
After all that
enabling is done, it'll
start the actual deploy process.
Now, a lot is going on behind
the scenes of this command,
which you don't need to know,
but you might find interesting.
What's happening
during this step
is that Cloud Build zips and
saves your source in a Cloud
Storage bucket, uses the Cloud
Native Computing Foundation
Buildpacks in the background
to build your image,
creates a registry to store
the resulting container
image, if not already present,
and creates a Cloud Run
service to host your app, if
that's not already present.
MARTIN OMANDER: Wow.
And, just like that, with one
single command, we're live, eh?
AARON WANJALA: Yes, we are.
MARTIN OMANDER: Well,
that was pretty simple.
But for my app to
get to production,
I'm going to need some tests.
And I'll want them to
pass before I deploy.
AARON WANJALA: Fair enough.
We can get that going
pretty quick, as well.
MARTIN OMANDER:
OK, so why don't we
get started by adding
a simple failing test?
The test checks if
1 plus 1 equals 3.
And it will fail, of course.
And then I will fix it.
And if all that works, I
can add real tests later on.
AARON WANJALA: Great.
Once that test is
done, we'll have
to inform Cloud
Build that we want
to treat running those
steps as their own step
and to stop if they fail.
MARTIN OMANDER: How
much config are we
looking at for this, Aaron?
AARON WANJALA: One file and
just a handful of lines.
I'll send you the
Cloud Build YAML.
This file tells Cloud
Build to run your tests,
install the project's
Maven dependencies,
build the image using
gcloud build submit
and the --pack flag
to select Buildpacks,
and then deploy the
resulting image to Cloud
Build with gcloud run deploy.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK,
that makes sense.
Now, how do we use it to run
the tests before deployment?
AARON WANJALA: Well, since we
have a Cloud Build YAML file
present in our
source directory, we
can just run gcloud build submit
and it will look for that file
by default.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
Mhm.
And, as expected, it failed.
Good.
AARON WANJALA: Yeah.
Now we can fix it
and rest assured
that we won't be pushing broken
builds to prod down the line.
MARTIN OMANDER: Very good.
Next, I'd add my code
to source control.
Then I'd like to
automatically run the tests
and deploy to my Cloud
Run test environment
whenever code is committed
to the dev branch.
AARON WANJALA: Those sound
like great next steps.
Let me show you how to do
them in the next video.
MARTIN OMANDER: Thank you
for showing me, Aaron.
And thank you,
everyone, for watching.
If you have questions
for me or Aaron,
please add them in
the comments below.
Also, let us know if there
are other topics you'd like
to hear about on this show.
Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]